everyone hello there my name is miles I
work at a company called famous
industries heading up the famous org
project believe it or not but I actually
got into programming through music and
art this is an example of one of my
installations that I did in my undergrad
it was called string theory it involved
cnc milling a bunch of wood a whole
bunch string a lot of string some lasers
some water some cold rolled steel I have
some scars from learning to weld it was
a great project and it involved
internally a bit of code with an Arduino
a bit of like hacking with the DMX
protocol it was just like I actually
found art was a really great way to
learn about coat and learn about systems
and how to build these large things
another project that I did was the
speaker bot this is a really quick demo
so I'll just let it play out so the
speaker bot had an embedded Linux system
and a Wi-Fi router in it and then there
was a connect hidden in the wall and so
using Skelton tracking I was able to
essentially make like a little theremin
type device another project that I did
was the voxel meter this is a fun
project using voxels to represent sound
and so what we're going to be talking
about today is a little bit of kind of
what what you're seeing visualized here
what does that mean what is sampling how
does audio get represented digitally on
a system so actually I should probably
pause that great so all of this started
with the device called a mano it's a
grid of buttons it does absolutely
nothing unless you program it to do
things and through that I learned a
programming language called max/msp it's
a visually based programming language
node based programming it's
really fantastic if you're an artist or
you know someone who's an artist or
wants to learn about sound or music or
GL it's a really great platform for
learning this it also allows access to
the entire internal API through
JavaScript and this is one of the ways
in which I originally got into
JavaScript was actually scripting in
max/msp for making installation art it
also if any of you are music producers
and use Ableton you can use Mac's to
control all of Ableton and all its inner
workings and this is just an example of
you know like how hairy a patch can get
it's a really kind of crazy way of
programming and if you thought you know
closures shifting right was bad just
look at some crazy max code but so my
love of music and technology brought me
to California to study at Karma the
Center for computer research and music
and acoustics wellick arm I had an
opportunity to learn about sound the
math behind it physics behind it how we
compute it Electrical Engineering and
most interestingly you know like how our
brains interpret sound so this brings us
to the topic that we're going to be
looking at today which is what is
sampling and so many of you might think
that I'm talking about sampling like in
the classic MPC sense of sampling blocks
of sound but that's not what we're
actually talking about today it's
technically correct but we're going to
go a little deeper we're going to talk
about sampling sound in the sense of
sampling individual chunks of sound so
that we can represent it digitally so a
definition of sampling is sampling as a
method of converting data converting an
analog signal to digital data digital
data which can eventually be turned back
into an analog signal so well we can
make sample many things today we're
going to specifically talk about
sampling sound so you can also sample
any sort of signal and a signal could be
you know like a potentiometer or a
button or a twitter feed could be
considered a signal I mean if you get
into really deep in sample theory like
everything is a signal and everything
can be sampled but we sample sound every
single time we make a digital recording
an unlike analog recording which happens
in constant time a digital recording
needs to be represented in sample blocks
you can kind of think of a sample as a
pixel for sound so I'm going to give you
a bit of a primer on some sound terms
that we're going to use to make sure
that you're all on the same page as me
as we're getting started sample rate
you're going to hear this a lot and the
sample rate is the number of samples
used to represent a second of sound and
a common sample rate is 44.1 thousand
samples and we're going to get into that
and why that is that number in a bit bit
depth and the bit depth is the number of
bits that's used per sample to encode
the data a common bit depth is 16 bits
codec a codec is an algorithm used to
encode a signal into digital data a very
common codec that we use is mp3 so let's
tie all of those things together and
kind of like figure out how this works
and we'll start by talking about a CD so
it's ed is encoded using PCM at 16 bits
per sample at 44100 samples per second
the algorithm is called PCM and it
involves basically taking each channel
and encoding it as a floating point
number between minus 1 and 1 there's
this is a floating-point way of
representing it there's integer
algorithms as well but this is just like
the simplest agrestic rock so we're just
going to talk about that and you can
actually think about PCM encoding as an
array and each channel gets interleaved
so we can think about the array of
samples that are on a CD as the first
sample left channel than the first
sample the right channel all the way to
like n number of samples that you have
in your recording and so this will be
referred to as a lossless form of
encoding I mean it's not entirely
lossless when you sample a nun sample
like that does disrupt the signal but as
far as encoding methods are concerned
PCM is considered lossless a form of
lossy encoding would be mp3 mp3 actually
uses a variety of heuristics based on
Psychlo acoustics to essentially say hey
we don't need all these bits and throw
them out and then like it's actually
lossy so there are limitations to
sampling though and those limitations
are part of the reason why we have these
random number
like 44100 so this makes sense to
everyone right no okay this something
that's called the Nyquist limit its name
it after Harold Nyquist his work was
built upon by Claude Shannon creating
what we know today is the fields of
sampling and information theory yeah the
Nyquist limit like really simply states
that the rate in which you sample a
system will dictate the maximum
frequency that can be represented in
that system so at 44100 we can only
represent samples and frequencies up to
20 2050 which sounds like kind of a
random number and anything higher than
that actually gets aliased around back
to the beginning and we'll come back to
that again and that's kind of like I'm
Metta thing but so 44.1 kilohertz not
gigawatts it's the standard sampling
rate used in audio but why it's actually
the human ear is the reason so the human
here only the human ear only hears
frequencies up to and around 20,000
Hertz so because of that we can know and
it's just a basic heuristic well there's
no need to encode any more samples we
could take 44100 samples we can
represent signals up to 20,000 Hertz and
pretty much everything that was in the
signal that a human would hear would be
represent would be represented it's an
optimization for compression it
minimizes the data that we need about
the samples so you may ask why would we
sample higher so some recording studios
will actually record at 96 kilohertz
this partially allows you to avoid
aliasing in 96 kilohertz I have a
diagram here to show it gives you a lot
more Headroom so you'll have what's
known as like supersonic noise that will
end up in a signal so if you're doing
like live recording in a studio one
thing you may want to do is actually
like record your drums at 96 k do a
filter of those top samples and then
sample down to 40 41 so you don't end up
having those high frequencies aliasing
and creating noise now when you just
have one signal it doesn't really make a
big difference but as you start
combining 5 10 15 different signals all
that noise starts adding up and you
start having a recording that doesn't
sound very professional so what is a a
lower sample rate sound like that's a
really interesting question a telephone
a telephone actually filters are
actually samples things at 8,000 Hertz
and I've got a really great live demo to
show us so here is an example of a
recording of a voicemail message sample
dick 44 1
I must be out or I pick up the phone
where could I
so if we were to resample that at 8,000
Hertz we're going to notice it actually
sounds exactly the way we would expect
it to sound on a telephone I must be out
all right pick up the phone
and that's actually not random that
phone is sampled at 8,000 Hertz the
human voice most of what is part of the
human voice that the ear recognizes sits
around you know like 3,000 to 4,000
Hertz so there's no real reason to
encode all that extra information and by
only encoding at 8,000 Hertz we could
send a whole bunch more data over the
water so let's go back to the human ear
and like let's get into some really cool
stuff and talk about what might why
music works so the human ear inside the
cochlea actually has an exponential
response so you have all these little
hairs so if we go and look at that
diagram starting at the center the hairs
kind of go out and they react to
frequencies in an exponential pattern so
as it goes out you know the response
rate I'm just describing something by
saying what I said it doesn't really
help so I'll actually show some diagrams
so an example would be a for the note a
4 is 440 Hertz the note a 5 is 880 hurts
this is like really crazy when you think
about it because as we actually
experience sound exponentially we
experience pitch linearly so there's
actually like this tie between an
empirical fact and kind of like an
emotional response as frequency grows
exponentially we experience pitch
linearly boom like that is so cool and
like all of music is built on top of
this this idea it was actually
originally discovered by Pythagoras as
far as I know and he discovered what we
allot of what we now have created and
know as the Western musical canon the
chromatic scale Pythagoras the diatonic
scale Pythagoras the circle of fifths
Pythagoras the greatest musical
achievement in the modern era well that
was actually fishes set to rotation jam
during deer creek sunday august 10th
1997 but yeah like they couldn't have
done that if it wasn't for Pythagoras
musical notes as we know them have
existed longer as a means of
communication than the English language
that's like crazy that gets me like so
excited it's like the idea that if
you're like playing guitar and you're
playing in a key that's like positive
like that's been communication between
people longer than the English language
now I know I'm probably wrapping up like
way quickly here wow it's been like 13
minutes I'm supposed to have 30 but I
think that's all that I have right now
on paper but that does give us time I
think for a couple questions about music
and sound if anyone has any but that's
all that I have for right now thank you
all go oh yes mm-hmm I can do a live
demo so you mentioned max/msp as in a
really great environment for artists to
look into music I was wondering what
kind of capabilities you had in that
yeah totally I'll just do a quick live
demo because we've got a bit of time so
let's take a look so this is max
we can go and we can start a new project
and we can start by just making a cycle
at 440 Hertz and we'll connect that to
the output we got some sound going so
what we can do that's really interesting
too is like any time you're actually
changing the amplitude is just
multiplying so we can take you know the
output of this and put it into a
multiplier here we can connect it then
we can make another cycle that's running
it like 10 Earth's we can connect that
and multiply by it and now we're going
to get amplitude modulation
and then we can take you know another
one of these and we can do frequency
modulation as well so we take another
cycle will put it through like a number
object turn that signal into like an
actual number then we want to do we want
to take it we want to add one to it so
that it's not zero based anymore and
then we can multiply it by like 220
we can just start kind of like changing
that
we could like literally just copy this
whole thing we can encapsulate it
we can duplicate it
add another one
popping this one
change this one to be like
that's music I guess so this is the
monome that I was talking before and
just let me know when we need to stop
because I'll just keep going so I built
this one a couple years ago I think I
can just kind of like yeah so the case
comes out and there's like electronics
in there it's really pretty and so the
case the top part is steel milled
aluminum and then this was like hand
routed it actually was another ma noms
case and then I got it secondhand
through a form you could tell the edges
where I roughly routed it to shove this
case in so that it all fit so we plug
this in it's going to give a light and
so there's some fun things that we can
do like really quickly with this so we
can open up monome cereal which is this
communicates the computer through cereal
monome cereal picks up the serial
communication and then converts that
into osc which is open sound control
it's an alternative to MIDI it's really
nice because it does everything over UDP
so you can do a lot more than you can
with MIDI MIDI you really only have like
128 messages osc is kind of like
infinite so here's an example of a patch
for a spectrometer so we can go and grab
my voice and then we can just see like
really quickly that and this is this is
like totally building on everything that
we were talking about earlier too we're
taking a sample of my voice we're
putting them through a Fourier transform
and so a Fourier transform what it's
going to do is going to take the sound
that's currently being represented in
the time domain is going to put it
through a transform and represent it in
the frequency domain so each one of
these bins is actually representing a
chunk of frequencies and then over time
were able to basically say hey you know
like I just care about the granularity
of an eight-by-eight grid and so we can
kind of like take a look at max
programming a little bit here if we dig
in this was this patch was written by
Brian Crabtree was online noticed n teh
n is the creator of the mono he's really
cool guy that this is basically
what's going on under the hood which you
know makes a ton of sense but I mean
like there's other fun things that we
could do to so like in Ableton for
example let's see if this works I can go
to my mu max for live folder I have this
one thing I really love using called
Raptor we throw a raptor in here that's
not raptor that's Raptors so there's
raptor and i connect raptor to the
monome and now it shouldn't be yeah
that's exactly what I'm expecting and we
can go and grab like there's this synth
I really love I'm called boards and it's
like a boards of canada ripoff
instrument everything sounds good like
you don't even need to like think it's
just like you throw this in i'm going to
like make up like a hit right now it's
amazing so raptor like i'm not a huge
fan of see so let's go into G and we'll
set up this loop group to be four bars
so we can kind of start
so we can kind of just like let that go
and just duplicate it and then just like
put in another syntha someone made that
I don't have to think about like we'll
just do something that has the word base
in it down that's not easy well you know
what's actually really great for not
having to think of it I really love not
thinking about things there isn't it the
instrument racking here has these like
evolving sits that are really awesome
yeah these rhythmic ones know the
ambient involving yeah something like
that it's gonna be music
you
what's awesome is out of everyone in
there
track so i can just go and
we put him on time
it's the one analytical GG
you know what my able to do
yeah yeah you know the rest on backwards
you got together always good
yo
so something like that you can do really
easily are there any other questions I
cool i'll call it now thank you so much
those amazing miles thank you